on parle de l'avortement tout de suite
ce combat pour le droit à l'avortement
il est en péril aux états unis on
commence par ce thème y en a beaucoup
d'autres qui sont vous allez voir
reportage signé flora sauvages
sont ils à la veille d'un tournant
historique en matière d'ibg mercredi
dernier lors d'une audience la cour
suprême s'est penché sur une loi du
mississippi qui interdit d'avorter après
quinze semaines de grossesse cette loi
viole le cadre fixé par la cour suprême
les magistrats de la plus haute
juridiction du pays devraient rendre
leur avis d'ici au mois de juin
l'égalité fondamentale des femmes et
leur capacité à prendre des décisions
fondamentales pour leurs vies sont en
jeu la cour a entendu tous les arguments
et les a pris très au sérieux mais il
est évident que l' affaire est
maintenant entre les mains de la cour
dans certains états du sud du pays comme
au texas li vg est interdite au delà de
six semaines de grossesse même en cas de
viol ou d'inceste dans son arrêt
historique roe contre wade datant de
1973 la cour suprême garantit pourtant
aux femmes le droit d'avorter tant que
le foetus n'est pas viable interrogé le
président américain joe biden a défendu
la jurisprudence existante je soutiens
recontre oued je pense que c'est la
position la plus rationnelle et je
continue à la soutenir aux etats unis
comme en europe le droit à l'avortement
est menacée en pologne ils restent
interdits sauf en cas de viol d'inceste
ou lorsque la vie de la mère est en
danger une femme enceinte de 30 ans est
récemment décédé car les médecins ont
refusé de pratiquer un avortement malgré
les malformations du foetus j'ai très
peur de ce qui se passe
j'ai une fille en âge d'être mère et je
lui déconseille de tomber enceinte pour
le moment en europe lit vg est largement
autorisée mais sous le poids de l'église
et des réticences de certains médecins
le droit à l'avortement est
régulièrement l'objet d'attaqués
et on débat autour de ce combat qui
continue avec céline pic bonsoir vous
êtes porte parole d'osez le féminisme
marabout sagon soir historienne des
états unis maîtresse de conférences à
l'université paris 1 panthéon de
sorbonne spézet du conservatisme
américain
israël nisand bonsoir soit aux faits
seraient mérite de gynécologie
obstétrique ancien président du conseil
national des gynécologues et
obstétriciens français et président du
fonds pour la santé des femmes
j'accueille également en visioconférence
jean quatremer qui est correspondant de
libération à bruxelles les européens
bonsoir jean quatremer bien bienvenu
merci d'être avec nous sans évidemment
matthieu croissandeau est toujours à mes
côtés on va commencer par le constat
américain tamara drewe ça qu'est ce qui
se joue en ce moment là bas parce qu'ils
jouent en fait c'est quelque chose de
très important c'est vraiment le cadre
juridique qui en cas de l'avortement aux
états unis alors vous l'avez rappelé
dans le petit reportage c'est la
jurisprudence de la cour suprême qui
fixent ce cadre et notamment une
décision de 1973 qui s'appelle aux
valseuses wade et qui en fait érige le
principe de la viabilité du foetus donc
c'est ça en fait le principe qui pour
l'instant président au droit de
l'avortement c'est à dire que jusqu'à ce
que le
que le foetus femmes tant qu'il n'est
pas viable l'avortement est possible
voilà et justement là on parle d'une loi
très restrictive en fait par rapport à
ce cadre là qui a été adoptée par l'état
du mississippi en 2018 et que la cour
est en train d'examiner en ce moment et
qui veut réduire ce délai à 15 semaines
donc on sort on oublie en fait ce
critères de viabilité du futur parce que
avec ce critère de mobilité on est
plutôt autour de 20 à 24 semaines
jusqu'à 24 semaines effectivement dans
certains états donc effectivement c'est
que c'est quelqu'un cas c'est 1,4 qui
est très permissif de fait aux états
unis alors qu'il vient bien sûr en fait
est qu'il faut ramener aux conditions
réelles matériel de l'avortement aux
états unis dans un contexte de pénurie
du nombre de cliniques qui vraiment
réalise les avortements aux etats-unis
par exemple
l'état du mississipi ne compte qu'une
clinique qui effectivement
réalise des avortements donc on voit les
cas extrêmes que ça peut générer
effectivement si le délai est raccourci
est donc ce qui est vraiment ce qui se
joue à la cour suprême en ce moment
c'est que si la cour disait que la loi
du mississippi était valide ce serait un
précédent en fait pour tous les autres
états notamment les états du sud qui
sont qui aimeraient adopter des statuts
similaire certains l'ont fait d'ailleurs
depuis notamment depuis l'élection de
donald trump il ya eu un peu un effet
trump sur l'activisme dans les états sur
ces questions et le précédent du
mississippi pourrait vraiment faire date
donald trump y avait évidemment
également nommer des juges conservateurs
au sein de cette cour suprême et c'est
pour ça que vraies possibilités et cet
activisme c'est une pique toujours sur
cet aspect américain on parla ensuite de
l'europe et de la france vous dites moi
c'est un combat sans fin c'est pas
nouveau un kla que la droite religieuse
porte ses idées aux états unis mais est
ce que c'est votre état d'esprit ce soit
oui je pense que c'est le droit à
l'avortement est un droit toujours à
défendre parce que on connaît toutes et
tous la citation de simone de beauvoir
il suffira d'une crise pour que les
droits recul et c'est ce qui se passe
aux etats unis le changement en plus à
droite de la cour suprême présage le
pire est vraiment l'avortement peut être
potentiellement en danger et les déjà
dans un certain nombre de pays et je
rappellerai enfin pour finir que trump
dans une de ses premières décisions
c'était le camp républicain sous l'ère
trump a aussi conditionné par le nombre
de sur les subventions à des hôpitaux
s'il n'avait pas de centre d'orthogénie
par exemple donc c'était des moyens pour
restreindre l'accès à l'avortement dans
pleins plaindre de détails dans pleins
d'état aujourd'hui c'est quasiment
impossible aujourd'hui de trouver un
centre d'orthogénie pour pratiquer un
avortement comme les états qui ont été
cités il soit disant qu'est-ce que
comment vous réagissez quand vous voyez
la situation aux états unis est ce que
vous mettez un peu la place de collègues
américains ou disant qu'il faut être
courageux pour pour pratiquer
l'avortement savent et y en a beaucoup
qui ont été tués mais oui et
il valait mieux tuer ses médecins que de
laisser faire l'avortement
nous nous sommes à neuf ce qu'ils ont
fait dans l'esprit de ce qu'ils ont fait
en france on a très tôt une loi qui
sépare les vg de l'iem g les
malformations et cette loi devrait dire
que kanye mg par d'interrompre ivg
interruption volontaire de la grossesse
img interruption médicale de la
grossesse qui a deux bras un bras
malformation foetale oui on peut aller
jusqu'au bout de la grossesse jusqu'à
cinq minutes avant l'accouchement seul
pays en france qui a ça en lui seul pays
au monde qui à cela et il ya un bras
pathologie maternelle ou grands
problèmes maternelle img psychosociale
on a séparé les deux lits mg
interruption médicale de grossesse n'a
pas de délai liv et g11 délais et
j'avais dire qu'en france ça vous parle
moins mais juste pour être bien précis
ça vous est arrivé de pratiquer des
indes et des avortements après douze
treize quatorze semaines parce qu'on
était dans ce cas de l'iem j'ai encore
une fois jusqu'à cinq minutes avant la
naissance d'un enfant ap terme quand on
a découvert une anomalie d'une
particulière gravité on est autorisé à
faire un acte qui s'appelle le foeticide
in utero
le même geste fait cinq minutes après la
naissance s'appelle un infanticide et
conduit son auteur en prison donc la
france a délibéré en 75 sur ce sujet
pour dire lorsqu'un enfant est gravement
mal formés et non
curables sa malformation non curables on
est autorisé et dans le cadre des
pathologies maternelle par exemple viol
est une indication psychosocial linsay
c'en est une une adolescente alors dans
ma région on n'a plus envoyé à
l'étranger de femmes depuis 25 ans
puisque nous avons tous dans la loi et
je tombe des nues lorsque j'entends
qu'il ya des milliers de femmes qui
quittent la france pour aller à
l'étranger c'est qu'on veut pas
s'occuper d'elle puisque on a tout ce
qu'il faut dans la loi et là vous êtes
sur la question du délai légal et du
débat
france autour de ce délai légal je ne
sais pas si marion et près de et près de
nous marions vigoureux qui la voit la
super merci mariant des treks je n'ai
pas ce que c'était pas prévu à ce moment
là mais après tout parlons de la france
tout de suite marion parce que il ya
effectivement cette question sur le
délai légal passé de douze à quatorze
semaines qui a été votée à l'assemblée
qui est en navette entre les deux
chambres parlementaires
comment ça se passe et plus pas mal de
polémiques ou d'indécision même au sein
du gouvernement c'est ça arrange vous
rappelez un petit peu le contexte qu'il
faut rappeler que cette proposition doit
elle fait suite à un rapport publié en
septembre 2020 qui révèle que chaque
année vous le disiez environ 2000 femmes
seraient concernées par le dépassement
de délais a dit vg bon contrainte de se
rendre à l'étranger pour avorter parmi
les raisons de ces dépassements il ya le
manque d'informations la pénurie de
professionnels et aussi le manque de
structures la proposition de loi qui
découle donc de ce rapport entend
renforcer le droit à l'avortement en
france et donc porté son délai légal de
12 à 14 semaines de grossesse le 8
octobre 2020 l'assemblée nationale a
adopté le texte en première lecture mais
le 20 janvier 2021 la majorité
sénatoriale le rejette estimant qu'il
faut conserver la législation actuelle
comme l'expliquent la sénatrice florence
lassarade le palier de 12 semaines n'a
pas été choisi par hasard c'est dans
cette période que l'embryon deux ans un
foetus et puis dans le calendrier
parlementaire nouveau rebondissement on
né le 30 novembre dernier la proposition
loi est de nouveau examiné à l'assemblée
nationale en deuxième lecture et elle
est adoptée donc c'est maintenant où
cela de prendre une douche oui mais le
problème c'est que si la proposition de
loi a bien été transmis au sénat le 1er
décembre elle n'a pas été mis à l'ordre
du jour pour l'instant donc pas d'examen
de prévu alors l'autre solution qui
existe pour les défenseurs du texte
serait donc de l'inscrire dans une niche
parlementaire une niche parlementaire
c'est un ordre du jour qui est fixé par
les sénateurs c'est ce qui avait fait le
groupe socialiste pour la première
lecture de ce texte mais cette fois ci
les socialistes ne compte pas sacrifier
d'autres textes à une proposition de loi
qui a peu de chances d'aboutir du côté
du groupe la république en marche son
président françois patriat a fait savoir
qu'il ne le reprendrait pas non plus
préférant privilégier un texte sur le
harcèlement scolaire enfin à droite et
au centre on estime que ce n'est pas la
loi qu'il faut changer et je vous
propose d'écouter à ce sujet la
sénatrice florence lassarade c'est
plutôt le manque de de soins
gynécologiques le monde que deux
gynécologues
d'opérateur ou sage femme
pour s'occuper de ses problèmes
fait que le délai vous poussez les
femmes ont des difficultés à obtenir des
rendez vous il existe une loi qui est
très bien faite il n'y a pas de raison
qu'on puisse pas l'appliquer à ce jour
il n'y a donc pas de calendrier
parlementaire pour une deuxième lecture
au sénat pas sûr donc que ce texte soit
adopté d'ici la fin du quinquennat
d'autant que le calendrier parlementaire
est très serré on sait que les travaux
se termineront à 2 février merci
beaucoup merci mario pour cette analyse
je voudrais vous entendre l'un et
l'autre sur cette question d
du délai légal pourquoi c'est une pique
vous pensez que c'est important de
prolonger le délai légal c'est
l'interruption volontaire de gaulle là
on est bien sûr sur l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse et pourquoi
c'est important parce que comme ça a été
dit à plusieurs milliers de femmes
aujourd'hui qui sont pas en capacité
aujourd'hui de trouver des moyens de se
faire avorter vont parce qu'ils sont
elles sont hors délai à l'étranger c'est
une raison suffisante et on voit qu'il
ya plein d'obstacles à l'axel ivg on
avait parlé en particulier d'un certain
nombre de désert médical où il n'y avait
plus de centres d'orthogénie ou plus de
médecins qui souhaitaient pratiquer des
avortements dans certains centres
hospitaliers donc il y as pénurie et il
ya en train dé fois dans l'axé ali vg et
donc il ya plein de bonnes choses dans
cette loi il ya leur leur allongement de
douze à quatorze semaines et là il faut
simplement comparer avec ce qui se passe
avec les autres pays européens douze
semaines c'est plutôt le minimum qui a
dans la plupart des pays européens sont
à 12 13 14 15 semaines et puis deux ou
trois pays européens sortent du lot
comme les pays bas par exemple
18 semaines en suède voilà quatorze
semaines en autriche qui sont voilà à 22
et 24 semaines en particulier donc là
c'est un no ce royaume uni un autre
débat voilà avec le royaume uni et les
pays bas mais d'aller jusqu'à 14
semaines ça permettra tout simplement de
diminuer le nombre de femmes qui sont
obligées qui sont contraintes d'aller
avorter à l'étranger voire même qu'ils
abandonnent un avortement et ça on ne va
pas le chiffre est quand on parlait de
traumatisme on a parlé un petit peu du
traumatisme des médecins de pratiquer
des actes jusqu'à 14 semaines emmanuel
macron à de plusieurs reprises dit que
l'avortement était un traumatisme moi je
revendique eux le trauma team c'est de
devoir garder un enfant qu'on ne désire
pas on y reviendra sur le
le gouvernement emmanuel macron israël
nisand qu'est ce que vous en pensez de
cet allongement du durée légale de
l'hiver j'ai encore une fois ça va je
fais des ivg depuis 40 ans 45 ans je me
suis toujours battu pour que les femmes
en demande 10 vg dans notre pays soit
traité correctement je n'ai jamais vu de
femmes qui demandent une ivg tardives en
revanche je vois beaucoup de femmes qui
demandent qu'on les prenne en charge
immédiatement lorsqu'elle se sont
décidés et quand on leur donne un
rendez-vous à quatre semaines en leur
disant rassurez vous
on a allongé le délai c'est un fort
mauvais procès qu'on fait aux femmes
parce que les jets sont deux tons plus
difficile et dangereux qu'ils sont
tardifs et j'en veux pour preuve que
certains pays qui n'ont pas mis 10 mg l
ivg bas ils ont tous mis ycompris les
malformations ils vont jusqu'à 22 24
semaines mais parce qu'il ya les
malformations dans le lot alors que nous
avons dès le départ séparer les deux
nous avons sans aucune limitation de
délai la possibilité de prendre une
femme qui dépasse le délai une femme en
déni de grossesse une adolescente qui
est pas capable d'avoir vu qu'elle était
enceinte et à strasbourg nous avons 2000
200 ivg il y a vingt femmes qui
dépassent le délai parce que nous les
prenons le jour même de leur demande je
dis que allonger le délai c'est un bon
coup politique mais c'est un mauvais
coup pour les femmes parce que ça va
réduire le nombre de praticiens qui les
font ça va quoi var et biot le bras
parce que j'ai été celui qui a été à
l'origine de l'allongement du délai en
2001 et je n'avais pas du tout anticipé
que le la nature du geste que ce soit de
manière médicamenteuse ou chirurgicale a
fait que puisque c'est comme ça 30 % des
médecins ont dit j'arrête et vous ne
pouvez pas contraindre un médecin qui
veut pas faire de faire ces gestes-là
j'ai invité beaucoup de parlementaires à
venir voir le geste voir personne n'est
venu donc je ne vous le décrit pas parce
que ce serait
pas sympa mais ce geste est difficile et
dangereux et je ne je sais qu'il ya des
collègues dans les cliniques privées de
hollande qui en font dix par jour qui
font payer 1000 euros le geste et qui
vivent de ça mais on trouvera pas ses
médecins en france alors moi je voudrais
rectifier de trois choses j'écoute alors
je suis pas médecin mais par contre
j'écoute d'autres médecins jusqu'aux
j'écoute par exemple gaga à thème qui
est présidente de la maison des femmes
de saint denis j'écoute aussi monsieur
faucher qui est spécialiste de
l'avortement et qui a fait de
l'avortement son combat il y en a
d'autres c'est toujours les mêmes donc
on attend je lui dis enfin pourquoi vous
me couper la parole premièrement je vous
ai pas couper la parole donc merci de me
laisser finir et je vais vous dire ce
que eux ont à dire sur ce geste ce geste
si ça prend tout à fait monsieur faucher
c'est le pratiqués montrent qu'il n'y a
aucun problème et il ya un grand nombre
de pays qui le pratiquent par contre moi
je trouve que la façon dont s'est
présenté comme étant un traumatisme pour
les médecins bien sûr qu'il ya des
gestes qui sont difficiles il ya des
moments qui sont difficiles pas pour les
médecins ça doit être aussi difficile
d'annoncer une chimiothérapie que
quelqu'un a un cancer ou pratiquer un
avortement ce n'est pas toujours drôle
d'être un médecin mais on peut pas
sacrifier les droits des femmes
sacrifiées le fait que les femmes ont
des difficultés à l'accès à l'île et g
en parlant en particulier je me souviens
que vous parliez de démembrement pour
cette technique il ya un mot qui me
choque franchement qui choque et qui est
fait pour choquer et moi je refuse qu'on
sacrifie le droit des femmes sur sur des
prétendus réticence des médecins mais
pourquoi les médecins ont-ils des
réticences c'est à peu près aussi
absurde que si on expliqué je sais pas
car pack un neurologue qui refuserait de
faire toucher rectal parce que ce serait
trop difficile à faire enfin bien
entendu que c'est assez pratique ça se
pratique dans plein de pays assure que
la comparaison pardon je suis désolé
mais quand même cette comparaison
excusez moi mais je suis un petit peu en
colère parce que là on est juste en
train de parler du dégoût des médecins
mais un moment est-ce qu'on se met à la
place des femmes est ce qu'on met à la
place des femmes qui pendant le
confinement dans pas réussi à avorter et
qu'on dieu qu'est ce que ça veut dire
aujourd'hui pour une femme de devoir
garder un enfant qu'elle ne désire pas
un enfant ses 20 ans à élever si vous
n'avez pas envie d'avoir un enfant et
que vous êtes contraintes de la voir il
est la vrai traumatisme donc j'ai eu
c'est vrai que les réticences des
médecins eh ben je suis un petit peu on
est un petit peu nous féministes si peu
agacé d'entendre parler de démembrement
et de gestes difficiles alors que dans
plein d'autres pays on la découpe et je
n'ai jamais utilisé le terme
démembrements hamas est ce que dit les
journalistes ni non jamais et est ce que
vous avez vu une seule fois une ivg
tardives vue je vous dis j'ai pas ce que
vous avez vu
venez voir madame je vous invite
maintenant ceci dit on a le même
objectif que les femmes qui ont une
grossesse non souhaitée puisse
l'interrompre en france et pas à
l'étranger ou jeudi qui a tout ce qu'il
faut dans la loi de la france pour que
ce soit fait en france il ya des
réalités je vais de l'un et jeudi que
obligions les structures de gynécologie
obstétrique
apprendra les femmes en urgence sur les
230 2000 ivg de notre pays par an y'en à
2000 qui dépasse peut-être le délai mais
c'est parce qu'on leur a donné un rendez
vous trop tard prônons les tout de suite
il en restera quelques centaines et ses
quelques centaines je propose qu'on les
regarde qu'on les accompagne qu'on les
aide qu'on interdise les envoyer à
l'étranger qu'on interdit mais que qu'on
interdise les oreilles un étranger parce
qu'on a dans la loi de la france tout ce
qu'il faut pour les faire en france
alors venir on y reviendra pas au jeu
en france c'est à dire une sampdoria
ventes à l'étranger si elles ne trouvent
pas de place en 2005 dont je vois plus
oui vous avez le temps l'un et l'autre
de revenir sur sur cette question mais
je voudrais qu'on se tourne vers un jean
quatremer parce que il ya la dimension
européenne aussi qui est très
intéressante dans ce dossier jean
quatremer et notamment il ya une
répercussion très politique parce que le
règlement du parlement européen va
peut-être offrir finalement sa
présidence à une opposante à
l'avortement qui est maltaise elle
s'appelle roberta médecin est ce que
vous pouvez nous nous expliquer ce qui
peut se passer là dans les dans les
prochains jours alors une précision
l'union européenne est strictement
aucune compétence en matière de droit à
l'avortement je le rappelle permanence
parce que beaucoup de gens s'imaginent
union européenne se mêle de tout ça les
malgaches et après jour avril qu'en 2008
après que les irlandais aient voté non
au référendum sur le traité
patrick jane et son traité lisbonne on a
rajouté un protocole qui rappelle que
l'union européenne n'a aucune compétence
en matière de droit à l'avortement bon
cela étant dit les perles dans
l'ensemble rythme européen
à part notre image et retour
il est clair que dans l'ensemble l'union
européenne on a aujourd'hui autorisé
l'avortement y compris en irlande qui en
2008 ne l'avait pas autorisé le sri qui
aujourd'hui interdit totalement
l'avortement ça fait mal or vous savez
que le la présidence du parlement
européen tournons tous les deux ans et
demi c'est à dire à mi législature en
valeur en janvier 2022
au moment où la france prend la
présidence de l'union européenne
le parlement va élire un nouveau
président mais après le socialiste
actuel qui s'appelle sa solide doit
succéder est normalement une
conservatrice et conservateurs européens
c'est-à-dire le parti populaire européen
où siègent par exemple élèves mais aussi
la cd ou cesse ou allemands ont décidé
de présenter une femme bonne nouvelle
une femme qui pays quelle saveur sauf
que ces femmes n'est pas n'importe qui
c'est une opposante extrêmement south au
droit à l'avortement elle a voté contre
toutes les résolutions défendant le
droit à l'avortement dans l'union
européenne résolution ne sont pas les
seuls puisque il ya pas de compétence du
groenland honnête et des résolutions qui
désormais aussi le droit à la
contraception ya dix mois de septembre
elle a voté contre une résolution qui
est passée néanmoins qui me demandait à
la commission européenne de criminaliser
les violences faites aux femmes alors
est ce que les autres partis politiques
c'est à dire les socialistes riou les
centristes ou si elle la république en
marche les écologistes et autres vont
venez pour sept candidats
c'est tout l'enjeu actuel est
normalement vu les mêmes - lecture en
cours autour du parlement européen sont
fait partie des postes puisque la
présidence du parlement européen je te
donne la présidence de la commission
transports je te donne 10 président je
te donne un poster et c'est donc chacun
a cherché real à sous et je crains et je
crains que le parlement européen c'est à
dire la majorité du groupe politique
nakk c'est une femme opposée à
l'avortement à sa présidence vous
imaginez la première présidente du
parlement européen ça fait six mois
nouvelle pour les délits non de 79 à 81
il ya eu aussi une autre fin résidant
près de 99 et 2000 avec de bilan qui
était de nicole fontaine ça fait 20 ans
que président et on va élire unsa
opposée à l'avortement qui ne se
préoccupe pas des violences faites aux
femmes c'est possible tout est possible
merci jean quatremer est resté avec nous
je vais vous reposer une question dans
un instant vous devez nous quitter dans
dans cinq six minutes c'est une pique
qu'est ce que vous espérez de l'europe
vous dans ce dossier je pense qu'il ya
des avancées à nous on réclame depuis un
certain nombre d'années alors juste une
petite une précision effectivement malte
c'est le seul pays où c'est formellement
interdit la pologne c'est tout comme en
fait c'est tellement restrictif que
quasiment personne peut réussir à
accéder à un avortement ceci étant dit
en fait on pourrait faire des choses
nous ce qu'on demande c'est par exemple
inscrire le droit à l'avortement dans la
charte européenne des droits
fondamentaux
ça pourrait être aussi une avancée et
essayer d'avoir de montrer de la
solidarité avec les polonaises ou avec
les maltaise qui vivent effectivement
l'enfer avec l'incapacité aujourd'hui
d'accéder à l'avortement donc ça peut
être déjà une première étape pour dire
que l'europe ce n'est pas que une europe
libérale une erreur économique et
montrer qu'on peut être solidaire sur
des combats de société comme le droit à
l'avortement qui est un combat essentiel
au même titre que la lutte contre les
violences faites contre les femmes
apparemment ce ne sera pas avec cette
présidence qu'on avancera sur ce point
alors oui effectivement c'est la
question que j'avais j'allais bosser
posée à jean quatremer c'est à dire que
c'est inscrire le doigt de l'avortement
dans la charte des droits fondamentaux
de l'union c'est possible ça déjà
le problème c'est que l'union européenne
n'est pas une fédération c'est à dire
qu'ils disent ils des compétences union
européenne qui décide de modifier les
traités qui décide de modifier la charte
des droits fondamentaux
ce sont les à
l'unanimité
c'est ça on consulte pas un peuple
européen ce spectacle met son veto et là
je peux vous dire que les maltais
mettront leur veto à une telle
modification
de la chanson d'un manteau ou des
traités européens mais on voit là la
france est face à un problème parce que
si ses députés la république en marche
c'est un peu le parlement ses talons
sans doute le plus féminisé jeu mois
après le parlement suédois si les
députés de la république en marche votre
candidat qui est opposé au droit à
l'avortement quel symbole pour commencer
la présidence française et qui se louent
ensuite pour aller 2009 ou aux polonais
veut dire demain on rire une seule
partie on va pouvoir élire un candidat
président parlementaire homophobes
pourquoi au moins on en est donc là
vraiment caisson valeur qui se joue la
france peut s'opposer à l'élection de
cette femme est petit on pe et goûter
nous sommes la majorité nous refusons
son élection parce que c'est un symbole
dramatique au moment où on voit que les
droits des femmes sont en train de
reculer notamment
avec la crise ils coronavirus à chaque
fois qu'elle écrit les premiers one
circus sont ceux des femmes donc ça
musulmans nous refusons qu elle soit
président si l'élu macro accès que ce
sera la mienne président de l'union
européenne de l'onu fahran européen là
on a nous avons nous français à leurs
problèmes merci beaucoup merci jean
quatremer pour ce ce focus sur la
situation en europe tamara boussac
est-ce que vous avez le sentiment que
les idées de la droite religieuse
américaine elles sont en train
d'essaimer en europe peut-être en france
aussi c'est un peu compliqué de répondre
à cette question parce que je pense que
l'émergence des droits de religieuses
sans fin son terrain certainement dû à
des contextes voilà qui sont spécifiques
au pays dont on est en train de parler
après il y avait évidemment des
circulations dans les idées dans les
pratiques militantes notamment des
organisations hostiles à l'aube ortement
qui viennent des états unis par exemple
voilà il ya certaines associations qui
en voit certains de leurs militants
leurs conseillers faire des formations
en europe voilà il ya des articles par
exemple sur des groupes britanniques qui
recevait voilà des des conseils des
formations de l'or de l'or on va dire à
leurs confrères américains donc dans la
sémantique dans les mots choisis par les
hawks a fortement vous retrouver parfois
certains des termes qui sont qui font
florès et aux états unis notamment soit
religieux oui oui bien sûr absolument il
ya tout un vocable notamment enfin ça
c'est ce que vous évoquez sur le fait
que voilà aux états unis on a eu
une des choses qui en fait est vraiment
condamné par la droite la droite
conservatrice c'est ce qu'ils appellent
les avortements de complaisance est en
réalité voilà c'est l'expression c'est
l'avortement à la demande voilà la juge
notamment émis koniba de la cour suprême
la dernière qui était nommé d'autre part
donald trump voilà n'a de cesse de
répéter cela que l'avortement n'est pas
à la demande c'est un peu ce qu'on
retrouve dans red en débat politique
français quand on quand on parle des
avortements de confort c'est aussi un
petit peu ce même voilà ce même genre de
vocabulaire qui fait appel aussi à des
notions de responsabilité individuelle
il faut faire attention avant de
s'engager dans des activités sexuelles
irresponsable par exemple donc c'est un
peu ce genre d'argumentaire qu'on va
retrouver oui alors je reviens la
situation en france et notamment la
question politique mathieu je me tourne
vers vous parce que vous l'avez évoqué
mais à demi mot et sans citer le
président de la république dans
plusieurs interviews et même wagon s'est
prononcé contre l'allongement de douze à
quatorze semaines c'était dans l cet été
propos qui ont été confirmés dans le
figaro il ya dix jours je vais citer
emmanuel macron donc dans l je n'y suis
pas favorable à cet allongement lives et
jette une conquête immense pour les
femmes et pour les hommes pour la
dignité et l'humanité de tous mais je
mesure le traumatisme que c'est pour une
femme d'avorter mathieu le président la
république n'est pas sur la même ligne
ou pourrait inverser la phrase le
ministre de la santé n'est pas sur la
même ligne que le président de la
république non et c'est un sujet qui
divise la majorité
olivier ferrand lui soutient ligne enfin
voit d'un bon oeil cette initiative des
députés il dit qu'il a saisi le comité
national consultatif d'éthique qui a eu
un vol qui a eu 21 pour et une
abstention et il voit en plus il est
médecin il voit plutôt d'un bon oeil
cette affaire le président lui est
beaucoup plus prudent il n'a pas marqué
son opposition absolue il a pris toutes
les distances que vous avez été écrite
après il ya un vrai débat qui traverse
cette majorité qui traverse d'ailleurs
d'autres partis
c'est un débat de fond il ya certains
qui sont sensibles aux arguments du
docteur nisand et qui se disent est ce
que le l'allongement du délai doit être
la variable d'ajustement pour résoudre
un problème d'offre mehdi d'offres
médical djadir d'offres thérapeutique en
france et certains considèrent que non
et puis il y en a d'autres qui
nourrissent quelques arrières pensées il
faut le savoir c'est un marqueur dit de
gauche pour une majorité qui est accusé
d'avoir fait une politique trop de
droite de manquer de marqueurs sociétaux
et donc ce qui se joue aujourd'hui dans
la bataille parlementaire je parle pas
d'une ou de deux du fond de la sphère
d'une certaine façon qui est quand même
cette détresse des femmes comment on y
répond et ce qui se joue aujourd'hui il
ya des gens qui sont sincères dans leur
démarche est qui et qui sont sensibles
aux arguments vous vous développer mais
il y en a d'autres qui disent ça serait
pas plus mal d'avoir un marqueur de
gauche on a donc christophe castaner par
exemple le patron des députés
socialistes qui lui considère qu'il faut
pour
tester son site un ancien social à des
députés de la république aux marcheurs
propres qui lui soutient parce qu'il
voit bien que dans sa majorité ou ça
tangue un peu ça permettrait d'afficher
un marqueur de gauche al'inverse
françois patriat le patron des sénateurs
a publiquement je suis dit je n'en veux
pas donc de toute façon pas le jeu des
navettes parlementaires et par le
raccourcissement du calendrier qui ne
s'est pas de la présentielle
cette proposition de loi qui a eu
plusieurs coloration politique un peu la
république en marche puis elle avait été
reprise par les socialistes pour
l'inversion de pardon je suis d'ailleurs
mais en tout cas visiblement peu
d'avenir parce que ça divise sur le fond
et les arrière pensées
nous convainquent pas les réticents
c'est pour ça la lisant que vous parlez
de coup politique tout à l'heure oui je
vais vous donner juste une toute petite
réflexion de ma part je préfère
infiniment prévenir une ivg que de la
faire nous n'avons pas fait du tout de
progrès en termes d'information à la
sexualité dans les écoles dans ma région
il ya un volontariat on a divisé par
trois les ivg chez les mineures on a
divisé par quatre les ivg chez les
femmes de moins de 29 ans donc ça veut
dire que ce n'est pas inéluctable et
quand je regarde mes voisins hollandais
suisses allemands ils ont beaucoup moins
10 vg donc ce que je dis c'est que et
dont les femmes avoir une contraception
gratuite ne mettons pas en berne la
contraception à la renchérissant faisons
en sorte qu'elle puisse être confiée
confidentiel pour les mineurs et
essayons d'éviter les ivg on ne parle
même pas de la prévention des ivg tout
se passe comme si on était sur un coup
politique et moi je suis sûr comment
aider les femmes de mon pays je
personnes aucun parent en aimerait que
sa fille de 15 ans termine sa première
histoire d'amour sur une ivg bien sûr si
elle est enceinte il faut faire libérer
et dans de bonnes conditions
mais si on peut l'éviter la grossesse
non voulue c'est quand même une
meilleure solution on n'a pas du tout
débattu de ce sujet c'est triste c'est
nous je peux répondre les jeux c'est
toujours un argument qu'on nous brandit
il faut prévenir les jeux légers mais en
attendant bien entendu on faut faire les
deux à la fois il ya d'autres choses et
d'autres petites positions dans cette
proposition de loi qui est porté par
albane gaillot accélère aujourd'hui elle
est ex en marche aujourd'hui
indépendante il ya en particulier le
fait que les sages-femmes pratiquer les
ivg
instrumentale et ça aussi c'est je pense
une ce serait une grande victoire et ce
serait aussi un geste lancé par la
majorité gouvernementale aujourd'hui
envers les sages femmes qui font grève
depuis très longtemps et qui ont besoin
et qui a failli qu'il est absolument
nécessaire de revaloriser
leur statut que leur rémunération et il
n'y a aucune raison aucune raison par
exemple pour lesquelles les sages femmes
n'avaient pas le droit de pratiquer des
ivg
instrumental jusqu'à présent il y a
également la question de la clause de
conscience spécifiques tant qu'il y aura
la clause de conscience spécifiques on
nous fera croire que diviser et à une
sorte d'acte à part mais en fait tu lis
vg n'est pas un acte à part dans le
parcours gynécologique des femmes je
pense que c'est la différence entre une
approche comme celle du dr nisand et
celle des féministes on rappelle par
exemple très souvent que dans les femmes
qui pratiquent les ivg 70 % ont un
contraceptif en fait donc temps qu'enfin
la contraception déjà mais fiable à 100%
il peut y avoir une oblique pilule à une
pilule pris avec trois heures de retard
il ya plein de façons et puis ya plein
de raisons il ya plein de raisons de les
fans n'ont pas à se justifier de
pourquoi elle avorte et pourquoi elles
ont elles sont tombées enceintes malgré
elles peuvent aussi changer d'avis on
doit simplement offrir la possibilité
aux femmes d'avorter sans jugement et
pour ça il faut dé stigmatiser
l'avortement a arrêté d'en faire un acte
médical à part et comprendre que
l'avortement comme la contraception fait
partie du parcours gynécologique des
femmes pour qu'elles puissent enfin
choisir quand et si elles veulent un
enfant alors qu'il s'implante deux
aspects dans ce que vous dites et je
pense que vous voulez réagir peut-être
sur les deux il ya l'histoire de la
clause de conscience et les sages-femmes
peut-être sur les sages-femmes pour
commencer si vous pensez que liv et
jette une simple contraception tout nous
sépare j'ai pas dit ça a redonné donc je
ne vous ont pas coupé j'ai pas dit ça
mais là vous déformer mes propos liv et
gênait pas une contraception
la banaliser c'est à dire en faire un
acte comme les autres où c'est un acte
qui nie la souffrance de certaines
femmes d'abord à faire ce choix qui nie
les séquelles psychologiques que nous
voyons dans nos consultations tous les
jours pour la finance sur un exemple sur
les sache madame pardonnez moi mais vous
pouvez pas me donner une leçon et
médecine sur les sages femmes elle
mérite qu'on n'augmente en salaires on
augmente leurs compétences c'est une
population de professionnels de santé
médicale qui fait un travail
extraordinaire qui met au monde 80% de
nos enfants en france dans de très
bonnes conditions elles font d'ailleurs
elle participe à 70 % des ivg qui sont
des ivg médicamenteuses chiffre qui est
en constante augmentation
il n'est pas question et personne ne le
demande que les ivg tardives soit faite
par les sages-femmes pourquoi parce que
le geste c'est trop dangereux et trop
difficile personne ne demande que les
sages-femmes face les ivg
médicamenteuses au delà dix semaines
parce que c'est un geste que les
sages-femmes ne
on jamais faire donc ça vient là comme
dans un débat qui est un débat
idéologique les sages-femmes ne demande
pas ivg chirurgicales où il y en a une
dizaine qui le demande dans le pays elle
participe déjà abondamment dit vg par la
voix d'yves et j'ai médicamenteuse mais
je réponds sur la clause de conscience
dire on va on n'a pas de moyens pour
faire les ivg en france mais rassurez
vous on va allonger le délai c'est
s'exposer à ce qu'un système déjà
déséquilibré
clash c'est à dire que y ait de moins en
moins d'endroits où on trouvera des
personnes pour le faire et adjoindre à
cela une restriction de la clause de
conscience qui d'ailleurs n'est pas
possible rassurons-nous
sansano ça ne le fait pas la clause de
conscience spécifiques et j'avais
participé à son élaboration protège les
femmes parce qu'on dit un médecin si tu
fait valoir la clause de conscience tu
es obligé de le dire tout de suite à la
femme et de l'emmener vers quelqu'un qui
fera l ivg dans la clause de conscience
générale qu'on ne peut pas retirer il
n'y a pas cette protection des femmes si
on enlève juste la clause de conscience
spécifique pour faire un coup politique
encore une fois en duo fait
alésien je réponds parce qu'il ya quand
même une certaine mauvaise foi ma phrase
était contraception et avortement font
pas font partie du parcours
gynécologique des femmes pour qu'elles
puissent être maîtres de leur
reproduction et de décider si oui ou non
elles veulent des enfants je n'ai pas du
tout dit que l'avortement était une
contraception est là aussi enfin
vraiment sur la question de la clause de
conscience
c'est c'est vraiment un argumentaire qui
est qui et qui est toujours brandi par
un certain nombre de médecins et on voit
que c'est un frein de l'axé arrivées g
si on compare par exemple en italie 1
sept médecins sur dix utilisent cette
cruelle clause de conscience pour ne pas
pratiquer des ivg l'accès à l'ivg et est
rendu difficile par les médecins privés
il ya effectivement un certain nombre en
particulier
deux médecins qui sont gynécologue
obstétricien et qui sont non seulement
exercent leur clause de conscience mais
sont objectivement contre l'avortement
et là ça m'interroge je pense par
exemple président alors qu'on dit il
faudrait améliorer l'accès les vg
faudrait faire des préventions du vg on
appris aujourd'hui le syngof
le syngof le syndicat national des
gynécologues et obstétriciens de france
qui était président en 2018 par monsieur
rochambeau monsieur rochambeau a déclaré
sur un plateau télé qu'il considérait
que liv et j'étais un meurtre donc il ya
effectivement un problème aujourd'hui
avec un certain nombre de représentants
qui ne favorise pas effectivement la
pratique de diverger et que ça soit le
principal syndicat des gynécologues
obstétriciens qui soit dirigée par une
personne pour des raisons personnelles
peut être religieux je ne sais pas mais
qui est opposée à l'avortement ça en dit
long sur aujourd'hui le frein que
représentent les médecins dans ce pays
et je ne dis pas le pardon je rectifie
pas les médecins mais un certain nombre
d'instances l'ordre des médecins par
exemple s'oppose à chaque fois à toute
amélioration de la loi le syngof
s'oppose systématiquement à toute
amélioration de la loi et alors que la
base des médecins je pense sont beaucoup
plus avancés les féministes et
pour conclure mais je voudrais vous
redonner la parole une dernière fois à
boussac peau pour qu'on soit bien
conscience cela cc c'est un débat
passionnant sur la france mais aux
etats-unis ils sont quoi ils sont
minoritaires maintenant les ultra
minoritaire les médecins qui osent
pratiquer
l'avortement ça dépend des états
j'imagine oui alors effectivement la
cause de conscience à l existant aux
états unis et de fait elle est très
invoqué ce qui explique pourquoi on est
dans une pénurie effectivement de
praticiens de clinique qui effectivement
vont proposer les avortements aux femmes
alors
d-will et les médecins se font attaquer
on a tous ces images en tête 1 aux états
unis d'aider des manifestations
extrêmement violentes qui peuvent avoir
lieu devant les cliniques donc il ya un
vrai effectivement il ya un vrai climat
d'angoissé autour de ça aux états unis
et ce contexte de pénurie du coup de
praticiens de clinique qui propose
avortement ça va mener notamment des
personnes à devoir aller dans un autre
état pour aller trouver un médecin une
clinique qui va où on va pouvoir se
faire avorter ça peut vouloir dire
parcourir des centaines de kilomètres
évidemment voilà ça avec des
conséquences dramatiques bien sûr pour
et personne n'éprouve plus précaires qui
ne peuvent pas forcément se déplacer
merci un dernier mot israël nisand le
nombre de centres pratiquant les ivg a
baissé de plus de 20 % en quinze ans
qu'est ce que au delà des propositions
vous avez pu faire qu'est-ce que qu'est
ce que vous voyez d'urgent pour inverser
cette tendance à tout le moins faut
mettre des moyens sur cette question
l'hôpital va mal ça ne vous a pas
échappé et les services de césariennes
comme les services de chirurgie du
cancer vont mal et ont des pénuries de
moyens je propose qu'on ya plus de
clause de conscience en france soyons
clairs je reçois 35 nouveaux internes
chaque année et il n'a jamais un qui
fait valoir la clause de conscience une
fois en 25 ans j'ai une fille qui est
rentré dans les ordres qui a dit je peux
pas mais tous les autres disent il n'y a
pas de souci on nous oppose toujours
l'italie et vite
l'italie c'est pas la france que
faudrait-il des moyens des moyens et pas
un allongement du délai comme ça à
l'aveuglent qui est un coup politique on
a bien compris vous avez plus l'une et
l'autre exposer vos arguments merci de
nous avoir participé à ce débat je vous
dis à demain pour nous